Hikaru Nakamura just became the number
two player in the world round five of
Norway chess saw Hikaru take on
ariantari one of two players on home
turf the game was tight until tari who
happened to be celebrating his birthday
made an error with Pawn to C5 Hikaru
created a powerful center with his
connected past pawns while also
immobilizing tari's pawns from ever
having hope to finish it off Hikaru
found a crushing tactic after Rook takes
Rook B7 and no way to prevent promotion
on another board tournament leader
Fabiano caruana based immense difficulty
against chakriar mamadierov with the
critical mistake of Queen D3 by Fabi it
was only a matter of time for Mahmoud
Europe to clinch the Victory and with
alireza farusa drawing Wesley so all
pieces were aligned for Hikaru to claim
number two in the live classical
rankings in the official rankings the
last time Hikaru was ranked number two
was nearly eight years ago in October of
2015 with a historic Resurgence of
classical form